you're fun to watch man all right what's
gonna be better like signing a new
contract or not having to answer
questions about getting a new contract
which will actually be better that's
tough probably signing that Prescott
Cowboys quarterback on the brink of free
agency before he can get the free agency
the Cowboys have a weapon in the arsenal
known as the franchise tag a report from
ESPN over the weekend suggested that
it's inevitable the deck will be tagged
which i think is craziness if it comes
to it it isn't that difficult at this
point to figure out what it would take
to sign dak based on the non-exclusive
franchise tag which will be in the range
of 27 million per year that's your
starting point 27 million with a 20%
bump for next year and you'll work it
forward from there under the exclusive
tag which would take him off the market
entirely no one could try to sign him
and give up two first-round picks as
compensation the exclusive tag is gonna
cost based on current calculations for
2020 thirty three point four million
that is a hell of a starting point when
you consider that Russell Wilson's
contract paid him 31 four million at
signing per year at signing a deal
premise on 33 for as a starting point at
signing would blow the lid off the
market but Chris that's the problem if
they apply the franchise tag it's no
longer about I've seen people arguing
he's not worth 30 million he's not worth
this it doesn't matter at this point
once you tag the guy he's worth what the
tag is it's like Kirk Cousins in
Washington was only twenty million the
first year and 24 million the second
year if you tag the guy it changes
everything and if you tag the guy Chris
I can tell you this he ain't showing up
yeah until you sign him to a long-term
deal or until week one maybe he stays
away the whole offseason preseason and
training camp and and gets that full 33
point four million dollars rolling
through the door a week before the
season well yeah I mean come on they got
to pay them I mean they got to do it
they get you know yeah okay maybe they
franchise them or exclusive tagging them
right right at first right just to make
sure that
no you know market and conversation that
way but he has incredible leverage here
he really does first off he's the
quarterback I mean he's the franchise
quarterback he's proven it you know Mike
I've been around him for the last two
Super Bowls now I mean I get it you know
he's got a great way about him I mean he
really does you could see that he
leadership being able to command a room
charismatic all of those things are real
let alone he's built like a Greek god
and he's really damn good at football so
there's not you know again the grass
isn't always greener doc Prescott is one
of the 10 best quarterbacks in football
so they're gonna have to find a way to
get it done and especially with Mike
McCarthy coming into town and Jerry
Jones as we talked about he's getting
old he's not getting any younger and if
he wants to maximize his his years left
on the planet to maybe win a Super Bowl
Hey yes get the job get the deal done
with dak Prescott because he is your guy
now the problem is Mike is like where do
they pay him you know that that's that's
you keep the tag guys you tagged him
that's the formula because the tag
especially the exclusive tag the formula
on which that would be based is higher
than the current market so yeah if
they're gonna tag it @ 33.4 million if
it stays there because it's an average
of the five top quarterback cap numbers
for 2020 and it'll change these guys do
new deals or restructure their contracts
but thirty three point four million as
the starting point that's fine with me
and here's the other thing too Chris if
he decides to go year-to-year right and
and let me say this the fact that
there's a report that the franchise tag
looks inevitable suggests to me that the
Cowboys don't believe he'll go
year-to-year because once you start down
that path you you the numbers go haywire
especially in year three and they may be
looking at only two more years with dak
Prescott if he truly does go
year-to-year well yeah I would hope he
doesn't go year-to-year and yeah I I
mean I understand the cowboy not though
why not
why don't get paid let me say this yeah
let me say this I heard stories about
the Jerry Jones yacht the 250 million
dollar floating palace right I've heard
we don't have enough time for me to show
but let let me just say this yeah from
what I've heard
is as obscenely opulent as you would
expect it to be right and when I heard
those stories
my reaction was dak get paid get
everything I know there's a salary cap
get everything because this guy can
afford to write the check yeah he
definitely can I mean yeah you know what
do they always say you know every
everything's big in Texas and Jerry
always does it big whether it's the
stadium is you know I'm sure you know
his boats whatever it is but but like
this is to me is inevitable and they
just got to figure it out as far as
getting it done as far as a long-term
contract I mean - you know what is the
issue for you like you know as far as
what he's going to be paid I know you
said it is of course the franchise tag
deal and the exclusive tag deal that
drives it but if you're dak Prescott you
know what is the number that makes you
happy on a yearly basis and are you
counting new money average salary now
there's no new money it's no new money
he has no contract unless it's only new
money if you're in the last year you
deal they blew their job without side
comparing it to the other players and
that - you know to me it's very simple
at this point and he has shown that he's
a businessman because he hasn't accepted
the offers they put on the table yeah 30
3.4 million this year you multiply that
by 1.2 a 20% raise it's 40 million for
2021 and if they would tag him again
Chris the price tag for 2022 for one
year fifty seven point seven G's million
right point is once you pull the pin on
the franchise tag grenade those are the
kinds of numbers you're getting yourself
into and it becomes very easy at that
point to do a deal the question is will
the Cowboys do it or just let him go
year two
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports